now the last time our next presenters
were in the Oscar show together was in
1989 so much has changed since then the
majority in Congress the cost of living
many of the breasts in this room
I really wanted to say that but
thankfully they're still together
please welcome back with Goldie Hawn a
mister quite Russell
after a movie is shot thousands of feet
of film find their way into the hands of
an editor and then it begins the
delicate orchestration as all the
elements of a movie are masterfully cut
together this year the nominees for film
editing are Mike Hill and Dan Handley
for a fall of 13 Markus Darcy and J
Friedkin for babe Steven Rosenblum for
Braveheart
this lemons on four Crimson Tide and
Richard Francis Bruce four seven and the
Oscar goes to Mike Hill and Dan Handley
for Apollo 13
I'd like to thank Universal Pictures the
Academy like to thank my wife my
daughter Jenny and Katie like to thank
Brian Grazer I'd like to thank Ron
Howard Ferrara frame of film he gave us
thanks a lot Ron real quick thanks to my
wife Leanne and my daughter Jesse back
home in Omaha and our great assistant
staff our editorial staff is fantastic
and of course the best director that any
other could have Ron Howard thanks rod